vous avez aussi une partie de l'argent
forcément qui va rester sur place et qui
va infiltrer l'économie réelle et c'est
là où je dis il y a une chance sur deux
d'être à un moment donné d'avoir été
confronté à défaut d'avoir été confronté
au trafic en de stupéfiant eux-mêmes au
moins un l'argent de la drogue
ça fait 40 ans que j'exerce le métier de
journaliste j'aurais pu m'intéresser à
l'économie à la diplomatie à la Bourse
etc mais ça m'a absolument pas attiré
donc je me suis plongé dans cet univers
qui était la police et j'ai commencé à
le décrypter et c'est à partir de là que
j'ai fait un premier livre d'abord sur
la police et ensuite un second justement
sur l'univers on va dire des grands
voyous et je me suis mis grâce au
contact que j'avais dans la police chez
les magistrats et chez les avocats
d'abord à faire j'ai publié un livre qui
pour moi voilà le livre probablement
fondateur de tout ce que j'ai fait par
la suite qui s'appelait parrain et caïd
c'était un ou du Grand mendis le
français où je répertoriais en donnant
les noms tous les grands voyous dans
toutes les régions de France le fait que
je ne les juge pas ces grands voyous
mais que j'ai envie de les raconter fait
qu'ils ont commencé à frapper à ma porte
et ce sont eux qui se sont manifestés
auprès de moi donc ceux que dont je
dresse et le portrait dans ce ou des
sont vus alors il y en a un qui m'a
écrit de prison j'ai demandé un permis
de visite je suis allé ça a commencé
comme ça et puis d'autres bah comme
Redouane Faïd par exemple qui m'ont
écrit de prison en disant oui le
portrait que tu fais de moi c'est pas
mal mais enfin voilà je suis le premier
par exemple à avoir parlé dans ce livre
d'un de Redouane Faïd qui est ensuite
devenu ce qu'il est devenu un braqueur
qui a voulu devenir célèbre précisément
et et c'est voilà la première chose
qu'il a fait c'est de m'écrire à partir
de ce où que j'avais fait pour me dire
mais ok tu as raconté ça mais il faut
peut-être aussi dire ça à dire si moi je
suis pas seulement ça en fait ce qu'ils
ont apprécié je pense ces grands voyous
c'est ma relative honnêteté vis-à-vis de
ce qu'ils avaient fait et que j'étais
pas là ni pour les envoyer en prison ni
pour dire qu'ils avaient fait le bien ou
le mal mais pour raconter de l'Intérieur
cet univers criminel qui m'a toujours
attiré depuis des années je suis une
sorte de funambule d'une certaine
manière je marche sur une ligne blanche
où j'essaye évidemment je fréquente les
policiers le matin et les voyous dans
l'après-midi que je peux prendre mon
petit déjeuner avec le patron de la
police judiciaire et puis déjeuner avec
un grand voyou qui règne sur Marseille
pourquoi pas il faut avoir des règles
des règles de conduite que j'essaie de
tenir c'est-à-dire de pas précisément
on choisit pas un camp quand on est
journaliste on raconte les deux camps et
moi ça m'intéresse de savoir comment les
policiers infiltrent le grand mentiste
et comment le grand manditisme
finalement essaie de déjouer la police
mais je suis pas là pour aider ni les
uns ni les autres donc la première chose
que j'ai faite c'est d'aller demander
des parloirs au directeur des
établissements pénitenciers parce que
l'avantage quand vous avez un grand
voyou qui est en prison c'est qu'il a du
temps il a du temps libre il va passer
chez être au rendez-vous vous avez même
pas besoin de son numéro de portable
pour le contacter donc vous arrivez à la
prison vous demandez l'autorisation et
là vous avez deux ou trois heures en
général à peu près libre pour poser pour
échanger il faut faire gaffe les
parloirs peuvent être écoutés par la
police donc voilà il faut il faut pas
les mettre en danger l'avantage quand
vous êtes installé comme ça depuis des
années c'est que quand vous débutez pas
c'est que en tout cas de la part des
policiers il y a jamais eu de tentations
justement de transformer le journaliste
que je suis en informateur jamais
heureusement d'ailleurs parce que le
jour où ça se passe c'est pas compliqué
c'est un policier tente un jour de me
transformer en informateur je vais
éclater de rire donc je pense que ça des
armera l'opération mais ça n'est jamais
arrivé parce que je pense qu'ils ont
compris en fait que je faisais mon
travail avec avec certaines règles et
puis de l'autre côté c'est pareil un
grand voyou qui me qui me poserait en
cavale j'ai rencontré des gens en cavale
ils me font ils me font suffisamment
confiance pour me donner des rendez-vous
où il m'appelle à partir de je ne sais
quelle taxiphone je ne sais quel truc
alors qu'ils sont en cavale ça m'arrive
ça régulièrement quand je rencontre des
personnes en cavale c'est parce que je
réfléchis moi-même à ce qu'est une
cavale et que j'ai envie d'écrire c'est
un sujet sur lequel j'ai un intention
d'écrire un jour comment on est en
qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on est en
cavale bon je peux demander aux
policiers des informations mais le mieux
c'est quand même d'accepter des
rendez-vous avec des individus en vous
allez devoir comment ils arrivent
comment ils sont habillés comment ils ça
coûte comment ils approchent le lieu de
rendez-vous
à quel endroit à quel endroit il me
donne rendez-vous c'est un bon sujet la
cabane c'est comment voilà qui est sûr
qui vous pouvez compter et à partir du
moment où ils me font confiance et où il
me raconte cela tout va bien qui veut
surprendre plus c'est régulièrement
effectivement de les entendre d'entendre
ces bandits me raconter y compris des
événements qui n'ont jamais été portés à
l'oreille de la police donc mais après
c'est un deal c'est un contrat c'est ok
d'accord il y a pas de problème et je ne
publierai ces informations que
le jour où tu auras disparu pourquoi pas
il y a pas de problème genre au moins au
moins je fais connaissance avec les
personnages si vous approchez pas ça
vous comprenez pas ce qu'il y a dans le
cerveau de ces individus qui sont qui
sont pas comme vous et moi ils sont pas
exactement conçus de la même manière ils
ont pas la même conscience de la vie et
de la mort et pas par la même
détermination non plus dans ce livre je
raconte justement les pionniers je vais
quand même rappeler une chose les
pionniers du trafic de drogue en France
[Musique]
si vous divisez par 30 ou 31 ça fait
environ une tonne 2 de shit qui sont se
sont parlé de l'herbe et des autres
produits qui sont roulés chaque jour et
chaque nuit en France c'est énorme là où
autrefois en gros les gendarmes
arrêtaient des gens alcoolisés au volant
tous les jours aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
c'est plus le cas ils ont ils ne
contrôle plus que des jeunes qui sont
sous-produits donc il y a une espèce de
transmission comme ça qui s'est faite et
dès lors qu'il y a un terreau on va dire
un terreau addictif je veux dire les
trafiquants de stupéfiants pour eux
c'est pas béni donc effectivement
aujourd'hui on peut considérer que la
France c'est le plus gros marché en
Europe la plus bon effectivement on
n'est plus nombreux que les Danois les
Hollandais au les Belges j'ai aussi ça
il y a le nombre qui fait voilà qui
induit cela il y a aussi des habitudes
addictives extrêmement bien implantées
dont profite d'en profiter les
trafiquants de drogue la première
difficulté des trafiquants c'est de
faire rentrer le produit qu'on consomme
les produits qu'on consomme sur le
territoire pour ça il y a pas de
problème ils corrompent des douaniers
des policiers des dockers à fond qui ce
qui d'ailleurs créé du chaos dans le
pays parce que forcément voilà ça fait
de l'argent qui commence de l'argent
sale qui commence à être distribués
redistribué mais après il y a une
deuxième problématique un deuxième
problème logistique pour les trafiquants
c'est que il se retrouve avec des
montagnes de billets parce qu'en général
les acheteurs ils payent avec des
billets de 20 euros par parfois 50 ça
représente des masses et ça ça remplit
des mâles et des caves anti et cet
argent il faut bien faire quelque chose
donc vous avez évidemment le haut du
spectre qui va partir dans vers les
banques vers le système financier
international qui va être absorbé par
les paradis fiscaux qui fonctionnent
très bien pour l'argent de la drogue
comme pour l'argent de la corruption il
y a pas de problème après vous avez une
partie qui va être investie ils aiment
bien la pierre les trafiquants de
stupéfiants qu'ils investissent dans la
pierre vous avez aussi une partie de
l'argent forcément qui va rester sur
place et qui va infiltrer l'économie
réelle et c'est là où je dis à tout
quasiment il y a une chance sur deux
d'être à un moment donné d'avoir été
confronté à défaut d'avoir été confronté
au trafic en de stupéfiants eux-mêmes au
moins l'argent de la drogue parce que où
est-ce que où est-ce que vous allez vous
est-ce que vous allez injecter ces
espèces ailleurs que dans le commerce de
proximité et donc vous avez sur le
territoire comme ça dans
le lieu françaises des dizaines de
petits de petits commerces ça peut être
des salons de massages des ongleries des
taxis fun des sociétés de VTC des fast
foods des choses comme ça ou là
sans le savoir vous allez en allant dans
ces endroits effectivement contribuer au
blanchiment de l'argent pourquoi parce
que ces établissements ils sont achetés
pas tous généraliser les parties de ses
établissements et des établissements de
ce type qui sont très clean très propre
pour pas jeter leurs propres sur tous
les petits commerces de proximité bien
une partie même des boulangeries parfois
j'ai vu qui était quand même comme ça
acheté avec cet argent sale parce qu'il
faut bien injecter quelque part
et après c'est au commerçants lui-même
de se débrouiller alors ce qui va faire
c'est que voilà s'il va vendre dans le
mois mettons
s'il va avoir 100 clients il peut en
déclarer trois ou quatre ans aux impôts
payer ses impôts et à partir de là
injecter l'art c'est comme ça quand
blanchit l'argent ce sont des petits
commerces ou vous réglez en espèces en
fait c'est ça qui est intéressant parce
que à partir du moment où on paye en
espèces vous pouvez tricher sur le
nombre de clients vous déclarez vos pays
évidemment des impôts dessus sur
l'argent que vous faites rentrer mais
après il est propre blanchi et le but de
tout tous ces trafiquants c'est quand
même un moment donné de leur vie ils se
disent mais je vais pas être trafiquant
jusqu'à 60 balais c'est pas possible
c'est il y a une limite comme ça une
limite dans ce métier il faut il faut
prévoir quand même un tout petit peu
l'avenir il y a un moment donné le but
c'est de pouvoir envoyer ses enfants
dans les bonnes écoles donc à un moment
ce qui ne meurt pas parce que quand même
la plupart de ceux qui ont énormément
d'entre eux malheureusement ce grille
les ailes et finissent au cimetière mais
ceux qui passent à travers le rêve
finalement c'est de des notables comme
les autres d'envoyer leurs enfants à
l'école et donc ils créent ces petits
ces petits commerces pour ensuite
essayer de monter en gamme et un jour de
devenir des commerçants tout à fait
honorables ils espèrent passer à travers
parce que des tests le plus le trafic en
deux stupéfiant c'est pas de faire
quelques années de prison ça il est prêt
il s'en fout il rend l'argent il aura
des mandats il sait que ça va
fonctionner ce qu'il ce qui est le pire
c'est de c'est de se dire que quand il
sortira de prison il ne pourra pas jouir
des millions qu'il a gagné auparavant
parce qu'au black confisqué en fait ils
ont envie de parler pourquoi les grands
voyous parce que en réalité ils ont une
vie comme ça de cavale permanente il ne
laisse pas de trace il ne laisse pas de
photo de derrière ils peuvent pas
laisser de carnet de notes ils peuvent
pas laisser de journal de bord rien
parce qu'un grand voyou par définition
il doit couper les ponts en permanence
et laisser de moins d'indice possible
à partir du moment où on arrive à créer
un lien d'intimité et qu'il se confie
vous rendez compte qu'en fait ils ont
besoin de se confier parce qu'ils ne se
confient jamais à personne et donc
effectivement j'ai pu écrire les
mémoires d'une bonne dizaine de grands
voyous comme ça de l'intérieur
grâce à grâce à ses confidences et vous
rendez compte qu'ils savent que leur vie
que leur vie
n'est pas éternelle même si ils se
prennent parfois pour des immortels et
qui se comportent un peu comme des
personnes qui vont passer à travers les
balles ils se prennent parfois donc pour
des intouchables malgré ça ils sont
quand même conscients du fait que leur
vie
ne va pas durer éternellement et donc
ils ont besoin de se confier ils savent
que en parlant un écrivain comme moi ils
vont laisser une trace de quelque chose
alors que sinon ils n'en laisserait
aucune